please open up  hey what's that accurate he don't know  that's Dee Robertson dude he was huge in  the 80's pop scene remember had that  song hammer of love I remember that now  actually his first film was German  sci-fi movie about a talking sheep  called uber baa oh the DP and the  costumer met on this show and they got  married and they have three kids now hey  what you doing man hey what's up man I'm  watching the finale oh yeah did you get  to the part where Jamie dies oh come on  man  are you serious ya know it's sick we  fast forward a little  [Music]  yeah so Dave for my work he said this is  like the best show on TV right now  and he knows TV okay you ready yeah all  right come on okay all right so wait  that's the redhead girl's father no no  the mustache is the dad what about the  tool man I don't like him oh he's that  guy  [Music]